iman chagnaud vous propose voyage sans
passeport
malaisie il de pennant penang cercle et
par la mer paris de fleurs et de palmyre
c'est apaisant que s'élève le grandiose
tempe d'ailleurs ital c'est une
merveille de l'architecturé locale
il faut pour y accéder grimper près de
400 marches et sur le chemin on croise
une multitude de petits temples aux
couleurs vives et autoire courbet
matin
le sanctuaire de la prière où l'on se
recueillent les bâtonnets d'encens
embaument l'air en se consumant
lentement et silencieusement bouddha
irait vers et
on a là
autant que des hyènes mittal on vénère
o'shea les tortues sacré qui grouillent
dans un bassin
et voici sept ans snap temps où je
tienne les serpents ça q
je ne sais pas s'ils sont féroces
oh
autre héraut de la malaisie
ces tigres ne semblent doux qui en fait
son et image un peu rien qu un superbe
but reste
à
pennant avec ses rues animées
rue bordée de cinéma dans les affiches
permettent à l'asiatique de ce
pèlerinage est curieuse idée semble-t-il
de la culture occidentale et si vous
vous promenez un jour près du port vous
rencontrerez ce charmant petit village
sur pilotis vernis comme un jouet
d'enfant
nous sommes installés ici pour le poète
et peintre avec ses toits green ces
passages étroits
on dirait sorti de quelques comptes
marins des temps passés
c'est aussi une cité assez curieuse nous
mêmes
dans les rues
vous croisez les enfants bien sûr il
vous regarde avec beaucoup de curiosité
il brouille sont adorables
mais le modernisme a fait son apparition
avec l'électricité et l'eau courante
mais à peine on revient toujours à la
mer si on peut dire que l'équipe est à
la mer est alors à ses plages
et à l'eau
you avec nouveaux chemins
cet avion pic vers l'est et nous conduit
vers un rendez-vous étrange et fascinant
celui d'une terre où la civilisation a
su encore se faire un peu oublié et il
faut prendre le bateau pour traverser
les nombreuses rivières il faut le
prendre souvent sur les cheveux on
croise un marché multicolore où se
retrouvent les femmes du pays
elles y viennent à ce marché vendre du
poisson séché et quelques légumes des
fruits des jardins voisins
voilà ces fameux poisson séché formes
diverses
c'est être excellent
sous le toit de son cap hong vu une
famille malaise
regardons les travailler chez aïcha à la
beauté des filles de quotas bienvenue
chez aïcha est heureuse ses doigts
possède un secret il tisse ses pièces de
soie sauvage brodé d'or que l'on nomme
sa ronde et que les hommes mettent au
jour de fête
inlassablement elle petit
regardez qu'un mentor et belle carla de
jolis reflets
voici son frère il est sûr et patients
les graveurs d'argenterie avec son burin
et son marteau il cisèle minutieusement
des cuillères à thé toute la patience
des asiatiques s'en vont se retrouver
dans ses gestes mesurés précis et
efficace
et là dans la rivière toujours la même
famille voici l'oncle qui travaille sa
femme
et sa petite fille l'ongle labour avec
les buffles l'attenté la fillette
arrache le riz la fillette est exclu
ce riz qui sera replanter pour la
prochaine récolte
c'est un dur et épuisant labeur où l'on
demeure des heures les pieds dans la
boue le corps dans une position
inconfortable mais les bras forte active
ainsi va la vie un quota chara plus loin
c'est sous une game où l'art ou la
rivière ou serpent sur laquelle vient de
glisser cette barque et non loin de là
encore et toujours c'est la mer avec ses
cocotiers dans lesquels palpite avant de
mouchan ce sont des traces de torture
elles viennent tous les soirs sur la
plage pour pondre leur jeu quel
enfouissent dans le sable et malheur à
elle si un homme les aperçoit parce que
je crois savoir que l'offre de tortue
est un mets très recherchés
cet homme travaille patiemment à
préparer la glu qui lui permettra de
calfater sa barque
voilà c'est une méthode originale mais
qui donne parait-il d'excellents
résultats
tout est paisible
tout est calme ici la nuit descend
doucement
du large ou en revenir les barques elle
rentre à terre
celles qui sont sur le salon les formes
étranges
pêcheurs rentrent
sous une lutte
smaïn immobile le coup la mer le vent et
face à la mer il ne reste rien
rien que cette noix de coco qui roulait
à la sab le mans aussi c'est le goût la
terre semble t-il dit entre nous on nous
a proposé voyage sans passeport cette
émission a été réalisée avec le concours
de henry de grandmaison et de solange
péters montage pierre-michel des scripts
vu cette embellie sont claude j mission
illustration sonore dominique pas
l'habit